that people only do what they know
they're going to get away with oh my god
shake my hand that's true i've shake it
i've taken everybody's hand don't worry
but that makes it worse though but no no
no no no no
i'm just saying that a woman only hit
you if she knows she can get away with
it like you're not going to hit a back
you're not going to hit that rule you
know what i'm saying so
we need to factor that in when we're
discussing this so are you trying to say
more men need to be more savage reader
no i'm not saying savagery but you need
to be able to control your situation at
home yeah you're right yeah yeah amber
has heard said on the voicemail she said
go and try and tell the world that has
been abused because she knew that she
knew that he's not on it
can i say something in terms of that
yeah because we we all have to put our
hands up here as i said i feel like like
he said people do certain things that
they know they can get away with yeah
we're all guilty of that in different
aspects of course i mean
okay cool i can be late to the podcast
nothing could happen about it i wasn't
happy
about all right i can't be late to work
because the more i get laid to work what
happens your pay or whatever yeah your
manager is going to say yeah yeah so
i'll get fired i think that's the same
setup that obviously they've built
around right
westernized countries yeah which is
our men are more powerful whatever
women we need something to or more
protection protection yeah but now we're
just now we're just to the point where
it's too far
like believe all women like what is that
that's what's going on now so you can't
because let's be rude that wouldn't
happen in nigeria no a lot of women
won't get away with that africa
it won't happen why wouldn't they get
away with it they wouldn't you would not
get it
the the dynamic over there is different
yeah different differences
explain to the viewers why it's
different so people understand it's
different in the sense of like there's
no law in place that really protects
that i'm not saying it's right but
people kind of know what they need to do
even to go further than that even the
police officer you're calling yeah beats
his wife so
he's just going to laugh at young girls
i'm not saying it's the right thing but
what i'm saying
i'm just
if you want to talk about like africa
like nigeria and stuff like that like
the dynamics over there is different
because
you're in a society where men
essentially you're not a provider yeah
women we still live you know like
uk or western world might be 20 years
ahead but they're still their mentality
and the way they do things they have a
way of life over there where
where like men are like the ultimate
provider women are just meant to be at
home
look after the kids and raise a family
right which to i'll be honest with you
that's a different conversation but i
don't totally disagree with the dynamic
but in the sense of what they what the
guys are saying is that
the
the power dynamics and the level of
protection that women have in the
western world
you don't really have that in africa so
it's like the police officer is a normal
guy probably he's being his wife at home
as well without when they step out line
up for whatever reason so it's like
you call the police of oh you know the
wife's cool
i'm getting beaten
let me explain you're going to come here
but yeah but he could probably yeah i'm
explaining to you fro like um
obviously i'm nigerian i mean yeah
yeah we can tell
the thing is nigeria is
i can't speak for every african country
in nigeria right it's um
we can say it's kind of like a lawless
state
now
um woman abuse domestic violence it's
not it's not accepted
it's not an acceptable thing where you
can just beat a woman and it's accepted
right
but
unlike here unlike here okay where it's
does the uh believe a woman uh movement
oh okay and things like that that
doesn't fly you know it doesn't fly in
nigeria
if
if you if
if a man just randomly
beats a woman right
you can get into trouble but also you
might not get into trouble
yeah yeah yeah yeah not literally i'll
break it down break it down break it
he's right trouble i might not get in
trouble so
i come from a country where wealth
really rules depends on your your status
rules right and it's a very loyal state
like here in the western world like uk
america
women like he said women know certain
things they can get away with right in
like nigeria you can't get away with it
you hit a man
except he decides not to hit you back
yeah you could it's he's not going to
decide not to hit you back because he
might get he might go to jail that
that's not the reason why
he might not return he's been a nice guy
because he's a night he might not
retaliate because he's a nice guy but he
just looks at you as fragile
not because oh he feels like if the
police comes i'm going to go to jail he
can knock you the f out
the police who come
help you from the floor and you give
them money and then the case is dropped
well that's that that's the problem will
be exactly yeah
the problem in the west is they've taken
away the consequences for women like we
can do damn
anything there's no consequence
and that's what we've seen like in the
past couple years with the me too
movement everyone just took her word she
didn't even go
like i think it's crazy that people were
dropping him and she didn't even go to
court she just said something like yeah
like if i got if i got abused i'm taking
that man to court right now
why do you think that's happened why do
you think the mewtwo movements come
about because girls like the attention
and the sympathy they get
yeah that was what sort of oh that that
part sorry
i think the me too movement like there
were girls that had valid complaints
yeah that's correct i think there were
valid but there were girls that just
wanted attention and sympathy that took
advantage of it
and so then the the companies just like
to be safe we're like let's drop
okay okay okay
because we don't we don't want it to hit
our pockets it's just about negative
and you had the crazy left where they're
just talking like believe all women da
da da da we're gonna
and and the other problem is 70 to 80
percent of consumer buying decisions are
made by women so
i was going to say yeah yeah yeah that's
what i was going to say yeah you know
what's so annoying about this situation
here why
i think personally
i would prefer to deal with with some
some of these situations back in africa
they're gonna carry the problem
for free no no no no no no not me let me
are you gonna let me land land reason
being here because even here the bad
thing about the setup here is yeah all
right fine your woman decides to abuse
your home all the time yeah
you can't even rally around like a group
of women
to deal with her you understand okay me
as a man i'm not going to touch you but
i'll get somebody that's on the same
physical level as you to deal with you
you can't even do that because you can't
get them
to do that she can also go and press
charges and said oh they've hit me this
and
it becomes something else what happened
to your legs
it's not about legs no no no no no let
me let me explain something to you
sometimes it's not about legs it's about
sometimes somebody needs to be taught a
lesson it's not about legs because okay
you run she she's going to try that to
the next man he runs he becomes a
generation of runners
he's correct generation
so you want to be the guy
to be the one to teach her a lesson like
he said we need to something so we i am
good i don't want to sit in a jail i
don't want to say enjoy like him smiling
in the ceiling like a black behavior
yeah who he'll be
you know
but what i mean is yeah sometimes
somebody needs to be taught a lesson
yeah and in all the teachers
because
you you look look at the end of the day
we have different viewpoints here and
you from knowing me for so many years i
just felt like you're just a strong
individual yeah but not everybody's like
that so because it's easy for you to
walk away you're fine with that not all
of us have that that mental capability
remember what i said i said i never i
don't disagree with what you guys are
saying i just told my mom but what i'm
saying at what point does this person
get taught a lesson you can't do it
through the law like what what do we do
they just keep on abusing men i'm just
getting away with it
[Laughter]
and you guys think
actually talking about that do you guys
think that's the problem though because
you know i don't know if you if you work
for an organization or you have your own
business
knowing that for example like what when
a t-shirt hit the [ __ ]
it's either not going to get you no
clients or your boss is seeing that i'm
like um we need to have a meeting here's
your p 45 like what's going on be like
oh i watch that channel
that's a very i mean getting fired is
more likely
i'm just saying if a girl is coming at
you like i used to i used to think you
should never hit a woman yeah
yeah i have said this until i saw the
types of shots these women be throwing
you're gonna have yeah i could do you
can expect to take it like she threw a
bottle at me pearl can you imagine well
you dodged it though i dodged it but i
couldn't have been his head he couldn't
hit my head nobody touched it coco for
life coco
all right the proper
all i know is i don't want to be part of
a generation of runners so i'm ready to
i'll just start in the [ __ ]
i don't want to hit no [ __ ] but i
just don't want to be a generation of
runners in it i already you teach
all i say to men is first thing to do if
you start getting into one
always just bring out your phone and
start recording thank you that's the
most sensible thing you just said right
today no he said no it said no uppercut
no no no no no no
nigerian way tell you what i tell you
why i have a friend one of my closest
boys
back in uni he got into
a coma from his girl
they go into an argument in his
apartment and she used um
she used something from the kitchen to
smash it on his head
the ambulance came that's crazy mind you
international students wow international
students so imagine getting your parents
getting a call all doing nigeria yeah
because of a girlfriend girlfriend now
parents that are that are old elderly
they start panicking
you know and this same this same guy was
the same same guy my friend he has um he
has a child now um
and he was the same girl no just another
girl is child mother he sends me a video
which i have
they
got into an argument right and she was
carrying she was carrying
his child the baby and she was holding a
knife and she was like ranting around
what wait let me finish she was ranting
ranting ranting and he you know he was
she didn't know he was taking the video
because she was ranting ranting that oh
i'll do this to you i'll do this and she
had the baby in her in the arm with the
knife in the other arm and he was out he
was standing standing at the back and he
was videoing me that oh yeah you do this
yeah and she was you know going off
going off then she looked back and she
saw that he
was recording he was recording that she
changed it and she was like i'm going to
tell the police that you tried you were
beating me and my son and then she
changed it and the thing is
when when the police come many neighbors
call the police
only a woman has to do especially if
you're with a child all you have to do
is start crying
men are seldomly heard but you're
speaking to my point no no so so what
i'm saying is
in in okay see the first case where this
first scenario where his ex hits him
with something and he went into a coma
she the girl didn't go to oh no yeah
yeah
now imagine if it was the other way
around
and at first she was first hitting her
he was trying to um he was just
defending himself he tried to defend
himself yeah because he's very calm he
was like you know what
he was it was in his apartment it was
like [ __ ] like you can have the
apartment he was leaving so but it was
when he turned around
to smash on his head and he just slid oh
he didn't walk fast enough now now
imagine if it was the other one now
imagine if it was the other way around
he would have been in jail yeah
so imagine if he was while defending
himself he got angry because of all
these slaps and he punched her would you
say you'd still be in jail as well
that's fine
i know the type of person well
the type of energy i give
you know you can't even play with me
like that come on jay
you can't even try it but
but you can't hit a man and hide in your
femininity
you can't hit me they want to hide
that i'm a female don't do it to me if i
don't hit you back it's not doing you a
favor come on don't expect it i agree
with that as well do not expect
me that you you shouldn't put the hat
you shouldn't put the image to put his
hand on his female on the female you
know
dude you should expect you take it i
agree you've said something and you're
saying something it's wrong hide behind
your femininity because
there are certain things that women get
away with that men get killed for by the
way
men get that
men are not that um
men are not that don't have sympathy
yeah presenting things to other men
they don't men don't know you get killed
for certain things you get killed while
you're saying certain things to a man
like